there's a new hero who looks mechanical  introducing Wave 2 of the Xenoblade  Chronicles 3 expansion pass for the  Xenoblade Chronicles 3 game  this is eno a new hero she appears to be  a mechanical  [Music]  complete her quest to have her join your  party  expanding your options for classes and  battle strategies  [Music]  challenge battles will also be added  test your metal and consecutive battles  against top enemies  defeat all enemy waves to earn rewards  challenge even stronger enemies to earn  valuable accessories and special outfits  [Music]  more hero and gameplay additions will  arrive in wave 3. wave 2 of the  Xenoblade Chronicles 3 expansion pass  Launches on Nintendo switch October 13th  [Music]